we just can't have nice
[Music]
things you know there's sometimes I
swear the universe bends around to mess
with my schedule because the actor is
still ongoing and as a result of that
while I do have every intention and I
will be reviewing the specials um for
Doctor Who coming out next month when
they air I'm not talking promotional
material I'm only doing reviews of the
proper s so I thought I don't have to
worry about Doctor Who news because
historically breaking Doctor Who news is
is repeatedly thrown off my schedule and
like I've had to drop everything else
that I'm doing to cover that I thought
well that can't happen not until the
strikes res
olved ah because this is all technically
business end stuff which I can talk
about and I freaking need to cuz what a
mess I need to give a little bit of a
recap for anyone who has not been
keeping up with this and also keep in
mind this is ongoing like I intend to
release this the day after I shoot it so
hopefully nothing major happens between
when I shoot this and when it comes out
but like this is an ongoing thing which
makes it very difficult to look into and
frankly a bit messy and that's beyond
the inherent messiness of the situation
so uh the entirety of the uh classic
Doctor Who B catalog all the episodes
from 1963 through
1989 uh were scheduled to be moved over
to BBC I player the claim or at least
the way it's been framed is that this is
part of the 60th anniversary like o you
can see them all in one place I suspect
that they were probably planning to move
everything over there anyway and they're
just framing it that way it's possible
that that's the reason that they're
doing it they're acting like it is I'm
not sure I believe that but regardless
um and I think I've had a hard time
confirming this I think this is only in
the UK because you can only get bbci
player in the UK uh officially and
so I really hope classic s on Brit box
in other territories cuz that's going to
be a big pain in my butt otherwise we'll
see how that pans out but regardless in
the UK at least um episodes are from
whatever other platforms are on I think
Brit box is over there as well um going
to be moved over to BBC player but
they've had to recently drop the news
that the very first episode indeed the
very first serial story of Doctor Who so
an unearthly child and then the
following sort of 10,000 BC kind of set
story that follows it is not going to to
be included with everything so basically
if you start watching from the beginning
of class you're going to start with the
doct and um that obviously tilted some
heads some people what what is going on
well copyright nonsense is what's going
on and this is okay this is such a
mess so there's a guy named je Coburn
don't be surprised if you haven't heard
of him if you haven't been keeping up
with what's been going on you probably
never have he's nobody and I'm not
saying that to like be derogatory
towards the guy but I'm saying like as
far as this industry goes as far as the
creative television film Etc industry
and all this like he's nobody he's he's
not part of this he never has been how
however his father Anthony Coburn used
to write Dr who and in particular he
wrote that first episode and the first
serial now this sort of before I can go
into things further I need to kind of
pause and talk about how dealing with
copyright um and who owns the rights to
what when you go back to the 60s and
earlier it has a tendency to get messy
now it tends to be a lot cleaner these
days because by and large most creatives
um even if they came up with something
completely on their own they end up
having to sign some kind of contract
with a movie St Studio a TV studio a
comic book publisher whatever it is that
they are signing over the rights to
their idea like they'll get paid
hopefully if they're not getting
completely screwed over they get
residuals but they don't get to retain
the actual rights for having created the
thing um that is standard now
part of the reason it's standard now is
because of a long history of different
people owning different parts of a thing
some ways that this is played out
historically for instance Spectre the uh
massive Global organization the James
Bond's
Nemesis that couldn't be in the James
Bond movies for a long time because
there was a guy who had a falling out
with the people producing the James Bond
movies who had come up with Spectre and
he claimed the rights on that concept
and I think in particular just the
script for Thunderball in general but
Spectre couldn't be used until they
finally got those rights sorted in time
for the Daniel Craig movie Spectre which
was terrible but that's a separate
conversation and that kind of thing's
been wrapped up in Doctor Who before
it's been noted by more than a few
people that um the dos and so forth have
had to be relicensed from Terry Nation
estate the creator of the dox um and
there's the the popular um rumor among
the fans that the show uh if not still
is was at least required for a while to
put dox in every single series of the
show um which is the supposed reason why
dollx would show up even in like one
scene cameos effectively like during
Matt Smith's run that's never been
really confirmed but that kind of thing
certainly can happen and those re
licensing of the individual who holds
the rights to these to these unique
Concepts yeah those have to be worked
out with each new thing now as I said
Anthony Coburn wrote that first serial
the first episode and then the stuff set
in the the cave people times effectively
now his son Steph Coburn he's the one
who's kicking up the fuss right now
so oh boy where do we start with this
basically because of the move to BBC I
player the rights had to be relicensed
and he has refused to do so and the um
his version of the story is that what he
he asked for what he felt was fair we'll
get into how much that might or might
not have been I'm not going to throw any
numbers at you but there's some context
to this guy um and he says that the BBC
was going to pay him a pittance and that
he's not going to relicense it to them
now whether or not he fully has the
rights and exactly what he has the
rights to might actually end up having
to get litigated in court but I suspect
the reason why bbci player uh at this
point is announcing like it's just going
up without that is
because they may it may well fall in
their favor ultimately that they don't
need to relicense this from this one guy
specifically again I'll kind of get into
some of the stuff with him in a minute
but that
this isn't going to be sorted by the
time this stuff is all supposed to go
live on BBC I player in time for the
60th so I I wouldn't be surprised if
ultimately he either does relinquish and
accept the pittance that they offer him
or they just wrestle control I won't be
surprised if either of those ends up
being the case but coming back to Steph
Coburn and giving a little more context
on him this is not his first time
pulling this kind of thing because back
in
2013 he tried to claim the rights to the
Tardis the vehicle itself the design
what it was and how it worked basically
claiming that because his father um had
come up with the idea which
is debatable but I don't want to get too
far in the Weeds on that but his claim
was my father wrote the scripts that
introduced the Tardis the Tardis was his
idea it was his intellectual property
it's now mine because he passed away
away
now here's part of what's annoying about
trying to look into somebody who is as
far as this kind of um content and
Industry is concerned a nobody it's
actually really hard to find out all the
specifics and the details because for
instance everything that I could find
every news right up for that case that
happened back in 2013 when he tried to
basically copyright claim the Taris as
his I can't find anything that wrote up
the resolution of that everything I
could find was being written you know
when he made his filings and his initial
claims and like oh he's claiming this
and the BBC says this and that's it I
couldn't find anybody having written up
a conclusion on the damn thing or at
least not anything that's currently live
and searchable that I was able to find
now my suspicion is he just lost because
he's not trying to claim the Tardis
anymore I think if anything had fallen
in his favor he would have been he'd be
doing that now but he's not so I suspect
what probably happened is if he holds
any rights it's just to those scripts
and those stories not the concepts in
them meaning not the doctor not the
companions not the Tardis not the time
travel Etc he probably has no lights to
any no rights any of the concepts but
what he's now claiming is probably a
little bit more reasonable which is
rights to those specific um scripts and
the things that were resulted from them
trying to parse what Steph Cobrin has
saying is very difficult
because all right I go way out of my way
to not speculate or comment on anybody's
mental state or mental
capacity because I think it's rude it's
invasive and it's nobody's
business that having been said I think
at the very least I have to say that
Steph Coburn has no problem coming
across like somebody who's a bit
unhinged I don't know if he is I don't
know anything about the guy but if you
go by what he is posting on
Twitter it it feels very unfiltered this
includes frankly Flatout implication
that the BBC literally killed his father
like this stuff gets gets so squirrly so
fast and he's openly
said the you know part of this is
frankly Revenge um he's made some claims
that his father was kind of screwed out
of things and that his father had had
made an agreement to just give the ideas
of his Concepts back to the BBC but he
says that was invalid because he was
sick and effectively on his deathbed so
that shouldn't count so again that's
kind of what I said at the beginning I'm
not sure how many of these rights he
actually holds or how many of or how
much of it is a case of he has a claim
to try and make but that needs to get
sorted out that's what I suspect is a
bit more the case but it's it's really
hard to say and how much money was he
asking
for if I were to guess probably an
unreasonable amount given that he tried
to claim the entire concept of the
TARDIS
before now here's the thing this entire
thing makes me just so infuriated and
frankly a bit uncomfortable talking
about it because I'm I'm not really on
the BBC's side here but I'm also very
much not on Steph Coburn's side because
in both cases it it's something I
fundamentally have an issue with I just
broadly speaking as a person as a
creative I tend to have issue with
people who make money by owning stuff
not by making stuff not by coming up
with ideas even in getting other people
to realize those IDE but people who just
own stuff and that gives them money so
this would be landlords this would be
most IP holders this would be patent
trolls there's a good example that
everyone can get behind as being
terrible if you're not familiar with
that concept these are people who buy up
patents to often to components that are
commonly used in larger things and who
then threaten litigation against anyone
who is using the thing that is patented
even slightly and then basically oh look
you can just give me this money and I'll
go away way and basically it's trying to
get money by doing nothing you have made
nothing you have done nothing to um you
know buoy up or or even really put in
the money to invest in the creation of
something and even that like I still get
squirly about that the fact that just
because you paid for somebody's idea you
now get to own that idea despite the
fact that all you did was have enough
money to do that I'm still not I'm still
iffy on that but at the very least
that's something if you put in the money
to finance something I'm like okay you
did technically do at least something
but with patent trolls like yeah they
bought a patent but they didn't they
didn't fund whatever uh creation made
the patent in the first place they just
they just bought it in like oo free
money
and Steph Coburn very much comes off
like that he believes he has these
rights and he just he wants money he
wants money because he believes he owns
the thing the thing is though so does
the
BBC the BBC makes all this money off of
Doctor Who not because they make it they
finance it sometimes right now it's
actually being financed mostly by Sony
and Disney but they don't make it they
pay people to make it they pay people to
be creative and make it and those people
if they're not getting completely
screwed over get residuals but they
don't retain any rights to anything they
did despite the fact that it's their
work and their labor the BBC gets to get
the biggest piece of that pie simply
because they own the thing so I'm in a
situation where we have two battling
sides of people who just want money
because they own a thing the BBC has
been the one who has been making the
money from owning it and Steph Coburn
wants money CU he believes that he owns
some of it now if we're going to be fair
if we're going to go who has actually
contributed towards this concept in this
intellectual property the BBC has
certain done more again at the very
least they have commissioned people and
paid people to do something with it
whereas Steph cobr just he just wants
money he's just kicking back and asking
for money and again I suspect probably
an unreasonable amount of it I don't
know that we don't know what amounts he
either was offered or asked for but I
suspect he's probably asking for an
unreasonable amount of money and this
has kind kind of made him for the moment
kind of the biggest villain in the
Doctor Who fandom it's like who the hell
is this
guy he's just somebody's son who
believes he owns some rights he also
seems to uh this and because this might
have been what kicked off the initial
2013 um lawsuit he was very very bitter
about uh his father's contributions not
being highlighted during the um
Adventure in time and space that was the
kind of the behind the- scenes the
speaking of Doctor Who how it first
started sort of TV movie thing that was
done but uh his father I don't think
appeared at all in his contributions
were not mentioned he seemed to take
that very personally which again is odd
cuz you didn't you didn't make a thing
your dad made a thing and I get like boy
I wish they'd given him some credit and
some do like I do get that to a certain
degree but he just seems to be holding
such a grudge and doing everything he
can think of that is possibly
conceivably or at least he can make an
argument is within his rights to do so
to just gum up the BBC because he's
spiteful and bitter and wants money
Cobrin has also implied that he intends
to publish the scripts that he now has
the rights to basically this seems to be
the way that he's going to try and still
make some money even though he couldn't
reach an agreement with the BBC and I
mean I guess as far as like a way to get
something out of this that's pretty
innocuous but given everything else that
he's doing this feels like him just
scraping the barrel for whatever pennies
he can get after his major play has at
least at time of recording not panned
out the way he wanted it to I think he
thinks he's waiting them out and I think
they are probably planning to try and
sort this out in the courts again we
don't know yet we're still in the middle
of it but we'll see the whole thing is
just a mess top to bottom because if I'm
being honest
the BBC probably did screw over his dad
at some point whether it just be in
terms of not giving him proper residuals
or credits for things that he did or
whether they did in some way um you know
Force his hand or take advantage of
someone who was in ill health to to try
and get the rights back I mean might
they have done that I could buy it I
could buy most corporations doing that
of of anything of size yeah I could
believe they would do that so did they
in some way screw over his dad probably
did they literally kill his dad no no I
don't think so for me this is a
situation where the fans suffer and
nobody's the good guy the slightly less
bad guys in the situation are the BBC
simply because they're not denying
anybody access to anything well I mean
they sort of are depending on how you
were getting do who before now you have
to go through BBC player possibly or
whatever but
like I don't like sticking up for the
BBC and I don't really think I'm
prepared to say oh they're the good guys
in the situation no they're just the
ones who are willing to make something
available to the public whereas this guy
is prepared to withhold it from the
public out of spite against them and
there are times when I can even get
behind that kind of spite if it's
something you
made not a thing that you inherited that
somebody else made
and you think you just are entitled to a
piece of a pie because you own a
thing unfortunately that describes both
sides it's just one of them the
individual Steph cobr is being far more
disruptive whereas the BBC is business
as usual so like that sucks in the usual
way whereas Steph Coburn sucks in a
disruptive way which is better which is
worse I don't know it's all messed up
but that that's the story of one man
holding ing the premere episode and
serial of Doctor Who
hostage I don't know if I'll do a
followup on this depends on how it pans
out like I said this is very much
ongoing it's very messy who knows where
it's going to go whatever your thoughts
are no personal attacks on Steph Cobra
and again I'm not here to defend the guy
but like keep it civil even in your
criticisms but drop whatever you're
thinking down in the comments and let's
talk about it patreon pays the bills and
is why I'm able to do this and talk to
you about these things including on a
quick turn around like this ended up
being but um don't worry too much about
that like share subscribe they also help
what I really want you to
remember you are
beautiful you
valid and you are loved you are the
council and I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council is
[Music]
adjourned time to thank some patreon
backers and in the spirit of October I'd
like to thank Robin MO
Zubin Lula goddess ala Tac the thing
that goes D in the anime Ruth Oliver B
solitary pictures or bton Melinda
Walters Jen Auntie Kate 808 Becky Sparks
FX The brutal Robin Powell Tracy scrapit
angry caspel Dave Hall and Rosalyn
Bennett thank you for your assistance
um I don't know I might try theming the
shout outs in the future I don't know
we'll see thank
[Music]
you
oh